ماسكي وعيد وتفعيل حساب ترامب على تويتر
ويفكر في تسريح مزيدا من موظفي منصه غدا
تركيا سنغارات على مواقع كرديه في سوريا
والعراق وتقولون ساعه الحساب عن اعتداء
اسطنبول قد دقت
قتلى وجرحى بين المحتاجين في ديوان درا
والامن الايراني يطلق النار على متظاهرين
فيما بعد
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
على حساب الرئيس الامريكي
المصري
على حسابه الخاص في تويتر وقال
الناس كلمتهم
مستخدم
سياحي عدد من انصاره مبنى الكابيتول في
السادس من يناير عام 2000 و 2001
رجعتي اخرى افادت وكاله وبلومبرج انا ملك
تويتر يفكر في تسريح مزيدا من الموظفين
بقسم المبيعات بالشركات يوم الاثنين وكان
مراسل العربيه ذكر نقلا عن مصادر خاصه ان
عدد الموظفين الذين استقالوا من شركه
تويتر بلغ
2100 موظف وياتي ذلك في ظل مخاوف من حدوث
انقطاع في الخدمه خلال الايام المقبله
وتعذيرات من خبراء من انهيار المنصه
تويتر
وبعدما كان واحدا من اهم المنابر لايصال
الراي حول العالم يواجه الان مصيرا ضبابيا
في ظل استحواذ الملياردير الى الماسك عليه
فاكثر من نصف موظفي الشركه اقيلوا او
استقاله عددهم كبير منهم مهندسون وتقنيون
الامر الذي يهدد امكانيه استمرار صيانه
الموقع بشكل يحافظ على عمله بانسيه
بعدما كان هذا المبنى شاهدا على قصه نجاح
تويتر الان هو مسرح هنا لنزيف من الموظفين
المستقيمين من الشركه استقالات واقالات
لاكثر من نصف موظفين تويتر تهدد مصيره
واحدا من ابرز مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
الموظفون لم يسمح لهم بدخول المبنى مؤقتا
وحتى يوم الاثنين بامر من مسك نفسه رغم
انه طلب الاجتماع بمن يجيد البرمجه يوم
الجمعه فخوره الموضوع تكمله في ان
المغادرين جزء منهم مهندسون وتقنيون
يعملون بالاساس على قائد تويتر يعمل
بانسيابيه وغيابهم يعني ازدياد احتماليه
حدوث مشاكل كبيره
وفيما يرى البعض ان استحواذ ايلول ماسك
على تويتر
خاصه المتعلقه ببناء تويتر اثنان الحسين
الطاوضه العربيه سان ف سكول
نشرت وزاره الدفاع التركيه على حسابها في
موقع تويتر صوره لمقاتلات تقلع لتنفيذ
غاره ليليه في موقع لم تحدده
وارفقت الصوره بعباره حان وقت الحساب في
اشاره الى الاعتداء اسطنبول الذي اتهمت
حزب العمال الكردستاني بالوقوف خلفه وقد
كانت وزاره الدفاع التركيه
على قواعد للمسلحين الاكراد في شمال سوريا
وشمال العراق قائله ان تلك القواعد تستخدم
تركيا
[موسيقى]
تعمل الدعاء العامه البلغريف ثلاثه رجال
من اصل النولدوفي ورجل وامراه ينحدران من
اصل كرديا سوري بالتورث في تفجير اسطنبول
يوم 13 من الشهر الجاري وفضلنا عن هجوم
شارع الاستقلال تم توجيهتهما تهريب البشر
عبر تركيا الى الاشخاص الخمسه بعد دقيقه
وتعاون وثيق مع ممثلين ادعاء في تركيا
المجاوره
قال الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجيه
نايف الحجره في خلال كلمته في حوار
يجب ان لا تقتصر على الاتفاق النووي وان
تكون الشامله لجميع سلوكيات ايران
وفي لقاء خاصه للعربيه مع وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني جيمس كليبرري قال كلافولي ان
التحديدات ايران لشخصيات المقيمه في
بريطانيا هي بغرض تشتيت الانتباه عن سلوكي
ايران تجاه المتظاهرات الايرانيه
ضد الحكومه لانهن دقن ذرعا بالحكومه
الايراني
على دول اخرى منها المملكه المتحده
اكد اكليفيرلي للعربيه ان بريطانيا ستحمي
كل من يتعرض لتهديدات ايرانيه على اراضيها
في المملكه المتحده بجديه بشكل خاص اولئك
الصحفيين الشجاع الذين كشفوا ما تفعله
الحكومه بحق الايراني تجب حمايه المراسلين
الذين يوفقون هذه الاحتجاجات وستتم
حمايتهم في بريطانيا
افادت قناتي ايران انترناشونال بسقوطي
قتلى وجرحى بين المحتاجين في مدينه
ديواندرا بمحافظه كردستان غرب البلاد وقد
كانت القناه في وقت لاحقا متظاهرين ادرعم
النار في مقر للحرس الثوري الايراني
بمدينه
مرموري في محافظه ايلان بغرب البلاد وقالت
القناه ان القوه الامن الايرانيه اطلقت
الرصاصه الحي ضد محتجين في مدينه مهبد
بمحافظه اذربيجان الغربيه وقد نظم طلاب
جامعيين في الاحوال زوجات طلاب جامعتين في
الاحواز جنوب غرب ايران نظموا تجمعات
احتجاجيه على تعليق دراسه الطلاب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا وقد اعلنت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه ان ما لا يقل عن
378 متظاهرا قتلوا على يد قوه الامن منذ
لاع الاحتجاجات في البلاد قبل شهرين
واضافت المنظمه الحقوقيه ان هناك 47 طفلا
بقينا قتل الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا نهار اسود
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اما السلطات الايرانيه فقد اتهمت من
وصفتهم بالاعتداء او بالاعداء الغربيه
بمحاوله اشعال حرب الاهليه عبر تاجيج
التظاهرات التي اعقبت وفاه الشابه ماسه في
نمره يحذرون يحللون من انها قد تنظر
بحملتي قمع اكثر دموي اتجاه المتظاهرين
بين المقاومه والصمود والقمع التظاهرات
الاطول عمرا في ايران يبدو انها تنزلق
نحوهاويه مزيدا من اعمال العنف المشهد
المحتدم اثار قلق الدول الغربيه لكن اكثر
ما حذر منهم محللون سياسيون هو لهجه
النظام الايراني
باتت عذرا له مستغلا هجومي
البلاد لتوجيه اصابع الاتهام لاسرائيل
وحلفائها في الغرب بالتخطيط لحرب الاهليه
في ايران
الاستراتيجيه التي تتبعها ايران اذا
تصاعدي نبره الشارع معها وتعمق رغبته
بالتغيير اوجدت قلقه لدى النظام من فقدانه
السيطره على المشهد لذا باتت السلطات
الايرانيه تبحث عن اعذار في مواجهه الرفض
المتنمي لها حسب محللين
وتفتح الباب امام ارهابي مدعوم من الغرب
طر قد يستخدمه المسؤولون كحجه
وحشيا ضد المتظاهرين
وسط ما يحدث في ايران من انفلات امنيا
ظهرت مخوفه من ان تستغل تنظيمات ارهابيه
الوضع لشنها هجمات داخليه وهو ما يتوافق
مع روايه السلطات الايرانيه الا ان محللين
يلاحظون عدم اتساق الهجمات الاخيره وهجمات
تنظيم داعش ويرونها حجه لتبني حمله امنيه
بردت فعل اكثر شده تعتمد على الخوف والرعب
وهو ما سيجازف به النظام وبنزلاق حركه
الاحتجاجات نحو العنف بعد ان بقيت سلميه
الى حد كبير روان حمزه العربيه
اعلنا قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
الجنرال مايكل كوريلا في مؤتمر في البحرين
انا قوى مخصصه للانظمه غير الماخوله في
الخليج ستنشر او تنتشر اكثر او ستنشر عفوا
اكثر من 100 سفينه مسيره في مياه المنطقه
الاستراتيجيه بحلول العمل مقبل لمواجهه
التهديدات الايرانيه
الخليج الولايات المتحده تستعد لمواجهه
تهديده ايران في المنطقه
قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه الجنرال
مايكل كورولا اعلن ان قوه مخصصه للانظمه
غير الماهوله في الخليج ستنشر اكثر من 100
سفينه مسيره في مياه المنطقه الاستراتيجيه
بحلول العام المقبل فاطلاق القوه 59 في
مياه الخليج يهدف للتعامل مع تهديده ايران
من خلال تطوير برنامج تكنولوجي مع شركاء
الولايات المتحده للتصدي لخطر المسير
الايراني يقول المسؤول الامريكي مشيرا الى
ان نشر هذه القوه ياتي بهدف الدمج بين
السفن المسيره والذكاء الاصطناعي
القوه 59 تم اطلاقها في سبتمبر من العام
الماضي في البحرين مقر الاسطول الخامس
بهدف دمج الانظمه غير الماهوله هو ذكاء
الاصطناعي في عمليات الشرق الاوسط بعد
سلسله هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار ضد السفن
القي باللوم فيها على ايران تقارير صحفيه
امريكيه سبق ان تحدثت عن عمل البحريه
الامريكيه مع دول في الشرق الاوسط لاطلاق
شبكه من الطائره المسيره لمواجهه
التهديدات العسكريه الايرانيه من خلال
ارسال هذه الطائرات معلوماتها الى الاسطول
الخامس
الامريكيه ما سيمكن من مراقبه اكبر في
مياه المنطقه هي خطوه جديده من واشنطن في
محاوله للتغلب على المسيرده الايرانيه
التي تعتبرها الولايات المتحده تهديدا
تكنولوجيا للامن الاقليمي خاصه بعد كم
الدمار الذي الحقته روسيا بنيه طاقه
الاوكرانيه لاستخدام المسيره الايرانيه
بلال البوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفي بعد قليل
رسميا نجم ريال مدريد والمنتخب الفرنسي
كريم بنزيما خارج تشكيله الديكا في كاس
اوديه في كاس العالم بقطر
اهلا بكم من جديد
يستخدم السلاح النووي سيجعل نفسه هدفا
مشروعا في اشاره الى بوتن معتبر ان روسي
اوكرانيا
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه ضافنا بلاده تستخلص
دروس من اوكرانيا لحمايه الشركاء في
منطقته المحيط الهدا
التقى الرئيس الاوكرانيين في العاديميرز
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه في كيف في زياره
غير معلنه وقلا سوناك ان بريطانيا ستساند
اوكرانيا حتى انتصارها في الحرب مشيرا الى
انه سيتم توفير 125 نظام الدفاع جوي
لمواجهه المسيرته الايرانيه التي تستخدمها
روسيا وهذه هي اول زياره للريجي سوناك الى
اوكرانيا منذ تولي منصبه
بعد انسحاب القوات الروسيه من خرسانه
احتدمات المعارك الشرقيه البلاد حيث صدت
دفاعات الاوكرانيه نحو 100 هجوم في دوناتس
خلال يوم واحد وفق الرئيس الاوكراني
24 ساعه تم احباطها في منطقه دنيتك وفق
الرئيس الاوكراني
الجبهه الواقعه جنوب شرقي البلاد باتت
الاكثر اشتعالا بعد الانسحاب الاخير
للقوات الروسيه من خلصن تحركات واسعه
ونشطه للقوات الروسيه جميله قصف مصنعا
لمحركات طائرات بدون طيار في مقاطعه
زابوريجيا وتدمير عده منشات لصناعه
الصواريخ ومستودعات للاسلحه الغربيه في
المقاطعه وفق وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من
جهتها قصفت القوات الاوكرانيه واحياء على
اطراف
واقعه في وسطها بعدد غير معلوم من القذائف
لحسب روايه السلطات الانفصاليه وفي محور
كوبيانسك على اطراف خارقيف ضد الجيش
الروسي هجوم الاوكرانيا باتجاه مدينه
الصواريخ الروسيه مراكز الطاقه وقواعد
عسكريه الاوكرانيه بضربات عاليه الدقه
اكدت موسكو انها حقق اهدافها بنجاح
على الجهه الاخرى
فكره اقرار هدنه قصيره مع روسيا على
اعتبار انها ستتحول فتره راحه لها
لاستعاده قوتها ورص صفوفها وفق تعبيره
ياتي ذلك وسط اتهامات تسوقها سلطات
لوجانسكي الانفصاليه للجيش الاوكراني لضم
اعداد من المرتزقه لوحداته او من من سموهم
بجنود الحرب
اعلنت وكاله الانباء القطريه وصولا ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الى
الدوحه لحضور افتتاح المونديال الذي ينطلق
اليوم وكان الامير محمد بن سلمان زاركم
حيث اصدرت السعوديه وتايلاند بيانا اكد
زياره زياده التعاون الدفاع والامني
والسياسي بين البلدين وشدد البيان السعودي
السعودي والتايلندي على التوافق على رفض
التدخلات الخارجيه في شؤون الدول وحل
الازمات سلبيا
بانكوك يتفقاء ايضا على تعزيز الامن
السبراني المشترك ومكافحه الجرائم العابره
للحدود والارهاب وقدما توافق على تعزيز
تعاون في الشؤون القنصليه بين البلدين
وبدورها على النت تايلاند ترحيبه ودعمها
لمبادرتيه الشرق الاوسط الاخضر والسعوديه
الخضراء
تايدها الاستضافه السعوديه معرض اكسبو
خسر الرجل الاكبر عمرا في السياسه
الماليزيه مهاتير محمد خسر مقعده
البرلماني في الانتخابات النيابيه وقد فشل
محمد البارق من العمر 97 عاما في الاحتفاظ
بمقادير الذي شغله
لثلاثه وخمسين عاما في هزيمه قد تمثل
نهايه مسيرته السياسيه ممتده منذ عقود
وحلم هذه محمد رابعا في الانتخابات التي
اجريت في دائره جزيره لنكاوي الانتخابيه
في اول خساره له منذ عام 69 وكان الرجل
من العمل السياسي اذا خسر الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
ذكرت صحيفه فنان سلطان البريطانيه
رسميا قلل الاتحاد الفرنسيه لكره القدم من
المهاجم الفرنسي كريم بنزيما قد استبعد من
نهائيات كاس العالم في قطر بعد تعرضه
للاصابه اثناء التدريبات وترى نجم ريال
مدريد الفائز بالكره الذهبيه الى مغادره
تدريب منتخب فرنسا امس بسبب اصابه في
عضلات الفخذ اليسرى
النشره للعناوين
ماسك يعيد وتفعيل حساب ترامب على تويتر
ويفكر في تسريح
تركيا
في سوريا والعراق وتقولون ساعه الحساب عن
اعتداء اسطنبول قدمت
قتلى وجرحى بين المحتاجين في ديوان دراو
والامن الايراني يطلق النار على متظاهرين
فيما بعد
دائما مشاهدين متابعه المزيد زيرو موقعنا
على الانترنت العربيه دوت نت القاكم بعد
دقائق الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]